and completes the three-point play
j.r smith came out of high school if you
recall
offensive rebounds 15-5 in favor of
orlando
crusoe's gonna get called for a push
from behind
jr won a title with the cavs 2016.
he's played 130 playoff games
caruso has fouled out of the game that's
rare
you must think it's a summer league game
where you get like eight or nine fouls
or whatever
yeah he wasn't happy perez he tossed the
headband he only played 12 minutes and
really
couldn't find any rhythm he had four
fouls in his first five minutes of
action
that was a cheap foul he didn't really
commit the foul
uh the defensive player kind of cleverly
pushed him into it that's why he's upset
the referee didn't catch it
but nevertheless uh six games six fouls
you're out home game for the magic too
you heard a hit the road jack from the
dj
nba bubble trying to make it as uh
realistic as can be
we gotta we got a coach's challenge
frank vogel
[Music]
one of my favorite memes on twitter is
the
alex caruso buff
this is going to be interesting i've
never seen a challenge
on a play that was like let's see if it
gets pushed
by the way interesting guy the sixth
overall pick back in 2018
very good shot locker in college hasn't
really done much
in uh in the pros kind of still behind
bruce i want to see this again
well they definitely took the arm so
whenever he was hooked arms it
disallowed caruso
to do what he normally would do on the
defensive end and it may have caused him
uh to bump into the player but it
doesn't look like uh
it ruled in his favor uh by that facial
look right there
i hate to see a guy get fouled out see
it is right here something like this you
see right there you're going to see he
gets hooked arms right there
it's it's it's a hard call it's a
scrimmage
friendly reminder you know thanks for
that thank you for the reminder
go back to my egg sandwich
you got another one james i have a
little
big game as a player though if you're
alex caruso and you know what this feels
like you have to be furious because you
don't you don't want to get out of the
game number one
because you didn't play on thursday and
in a play like that that didn't
have anything to do with the play yeah
like you said it's an accidental lock
arms
tough when it toughed them to reverse
too because it's really not enough there
to change it but uh yeah it's
frustrating you know
uh you get those kind of files that
referees don't
really see it and you got to go sit down
crew so probably chomping at the bit
didn't play that last game because of
that bruised back
probably just eager to get out there and
show what he can do tough to see him
pick up those six fouls